la comédie française en alternance
jusqu'au 30 juillet il y a le
misanthrope et les fausses confidences
nous avions vu le misanthrope l'autre
fois maintenant les fausses confidences
vous connaissez le sujet vous savez
l'auteur ce n'est pas une question c'est
marivaux les mises en scène de michel
etcheverry avec claude winter dans hara
main et simoen d'andorrans il y à
beaucoup d'autres comédiens de qualité
comme toujours français la comédie
française jusqu'au 30
je lui dirai et je vous garantis que
vous resterez ici je roule 3 ils
changent de couleur que différence pour
moi
[Musique]
écrivez le billet que je vais vous dites
il ya tout ce qu'il faut sur cette femme
pour qui est sorti d'ici extrêmement
inquiet et que je vais surprendre bien
agréablement par le petit mot que vous
allez lui écrire en mon nom vient vous
n'allez pas à la table pour aller vous
oui madame ne sait ce qu'il fait voyance
et ça continuera
dubois m'a trompée elle couperait madame
je le trouve très le papier
un an voilà devant bouffe il est vrai
écrit
hâtez vous de venir monsieur votre
mariage est sûre avec vous écrit comment
madame
écoutez donc hâtez vous de venir
monsieur votre mariage est sûr madame
veut que je vous l'écris ve et vous
attend pour vous le dire il souffre
minimaux s qui ne parlera pas naître et
muet pointent cette résolution à la
crainte que madame on pourrait avoir des
suites d'un procès dit je vous assurer
que vous gagneriez douteux ma famille le
lait points non monsieur je suis chargé
de sa part de vous assurer que la seule
justice qu'elles rentrent à votre mérite
la détermine si je suis père d'une mère
madame vous n'aviez aucun penchant pour
lui qu'elle rentre à votre mairie la
détermin je crois que là même où
tremblent
vous paraissez changé que ça signifie
vous trouvez-vous mal je ne me trouve
pas bien
si subitement saglier la lettre y mettez
à monsieur le comte dans les monts vous
dirai à du bois ton avis portent le club
va
[Musique]